seit jahren kämpft sie für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in der
textilindustrie sandra dusch silva hat
betriebe in asien im blick bei denen
auch deutsche discount ketten
produzieren lassen
das familienunternehmen c&a ist einer
der größten mode discounter in europa
die meisten dieser pullover und hosen
kommen aus bangladesch indien oder china
dort arbeitet eine näherin 14 stunden am
tag und verdient im schnitt nur 30 euro
im monat hat sandra dusch recherchiert
selbst in bangladesch kann man davon
kaum leben
wenn ein shirt aber nur zwölf euro
kostet ist der preis extrem knapp
kalkuliert den ganzen transportweg von
bangladesch hierher an der ganzen
textilen kette würde man was dran
verdienen
irgendwo werden abstriche gemacht und
meistens beim schwächsten glied beim
näheren und nähren sie das letztlich
herstellen
c&a selbst will sich zu dem aktuellen
brand in einer textilfabrik in
bangladesch erst äußern wenn eigene
ermittlungen abgeschlossen sind
selbst der branchenverband sieht aber
die preispolitik der discounter kritisch
jedes unternehmen ist aufgerufen
verantwortungsvoll zu handeln
wer langfristig erfolg haben möchte muss
den widerstreit zwischen gewinn auf der
einen seite und moral auf der anderen
seite managen
diese näherinnen stellen unterwäsche her
zu deutschen tariflöhnen mit strengen
arbeitsschutzvorschriften das
modeunternehmen bruno banani in chemnitz
behauptet sich trotzdem am markt seit 19
jahren
wolfgang glasner und sein sohn setzen
auf made in germany denn das so sagen
sie honorieren ihre kunden auch wenn die
produkte vergleichsweise teuer sind
die herstellung in deutschland mache das
unternehmen sogar flexibler als die
konkurrenz
sechs bis acht wochen laufen die teile
bei uns durch winter stoff gekommen ist
das heißt wir sind vielmehr am
auslieferungstermin mit der entscheidung
wie viel stück wir produzieren wenn wir
zum beispiel in fernost produzieren
müssen wir acht monate vorher schon die
auflage festlegen
und da wissen wir oft noch gar nicht wie
viel wir davon verkaufen
seine stoffe kaufte der mittelständler
in italien frankreich und deutschland
auch wenn die preise hoch sind dass
viele modeketten immer billiger
produzieren wollen bringe so der junior
chef mehr nachteile als nutzen die
hersteller auch wenn sie bemüht sind und
manche sind ja wirklich bemüht ist es
für die unheimlich schwer die
lieferkette an sich im ganzen zu
kontrollieren und im griff zu haben weil
eben auch viele aufträge wieder einen
subunternehmer vergeben werden
und das ist einfach da nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar
auch bei modeketten wie c&a würden viele
kunden ein paar euro mehr bezahlen sagt
sandra dusch silva wenn dadurch die
arbeitsbedingungen besser werden
das hätten befragungen gezeigt löhne
seien nur ein aspekt in kaum einer
fabrik gebe es brandschutz abkommen und
nur selten unabhängige kontrollen
dadurch profilieren würde dass sie sagen
okay unterschreiben brandschutz abkommen
wir werden jetzt aktiv mehr machen
initiative wir treten der verwerfung
nation beispielsweise auch bei und
werden uns einen überblick verschaffen
über unsere ganzen produktionskette und
werden gezielt aufträge vergeben wo
bessere löhne gezahlt werden
sie würden sich von mit wettbewerbern
komplett gut positiv absetzen
bisher aber setzten discounter wie die
deutsche kette kik ausschließlich auf
preisdumping kik gehört nicht zu den
unternehmen die unser verband vertritt
aber ich glaube jedem ist klar wenn ein
t shirt 2 euro 99 kostet kann das nicht
anständig und fair produziert worden
sein
es gibt ein billig segment das wächst es
wird immer größer tk 2500 filialen
da gehen menschen hin die nicht anders
können weil sie von hartz 4 leben aber
da gehen auch ganz viele menschen hin
die sich etwas teureres leisten können
denen es schlichtweg egal ist
am ende entscheidet der kunde nur wenn
er keine billig textilien aus
bangladesch kauft müssen die discount
ketten ihr geschäftsmodell ändern